well thank you Jim and thank you David
and thank all of you for for coming out
um I'm I'm actually not going to talk
about capitals I'm going to talk about
one Capital which is Washington
DC um and um I guess I'll try to give a
little bit of an answer to The $64,000
Question that Ed uh asked because uh
what I want to talk about today is also
one case which is
Syria and what I want to ask
is why has the response to Syria failed
I don't think we have to ask the
question of whether or not that's a
failed response that's that's clearly
so but it's important to understand what
lessons we can draw from that failure
and therefore what meaning that failure
has so I want to First think a little
bit about the kinds of failures that one
can have in relationship to this
question of
atrocities so to think about the norm
that it talked about the responsibility
to
protect there are different ways this
failure can happen for example the
atrocities might not reach the threshold
that's set out by that Norm for example
there was a big debate when the
government of Burma failed to respond to
cyclone narus and the fear was that tens
of thousands of people would be killed
uh did reached that threshold no no
Perhaps Perhaps it didn't there similar
questions maybe when there was talk
about responding in in Zimbabwe in some
of the worst moments there under
President mugabi so that's that's one
kind another kind of failure is when a
key State blocks action so for example
in the case of
darur uh China consistently refused to
allow any serious robust action to be
marshaled by uh the UN Security Council
it really until it was too late until
the the overwhelming fraction of the
killing uh had taken place and of course
China had Russia on its side as
well third cause it's too complicated
there's not a a meaningful way to
respond yes you recognize that uh
unspeakable atrocities uh are taking
place and and yes there's a wish to act
uh but but it's impossible to find the
way in there's not a a a a to that the
International Community has and this uh
probably the worst example would be the
Democratic Republic of Congo uh where
you have a situation so so vast and so
chaotic um so
ungraspable that even though millions of
people have died uh even if you had uh
gathered up all the political world will
in the world you probably wouldn't have
been able to stop
it and then there's the the fourth
cause which is the thing that is our
inheritance today from the failure to
act in Rwanda and that's the failure of
political
will there is the capacity to act there
is the clear recognition of the need to
act there is no insuperable political
bar to act but there's a failure to act
and so this after all is the most
fundamental of all the questions and
when people like Samantha power books
like a problem from hell that is the
great indictment there could have been
action there wasn't and so okay so let's
let's think about Syria what what is
what does Syria mean in regard to these
kinds of failures we can dismiss the
first one right away obviously there is
no question that a situation where
perhaps 170,000 people have died of whom
perhaps about a half between 40% and 50%
are civilians
constitutes uh atrocities in the meaning
of the responsibility to protect it's
not you doesn't not it does not as Ed
pointed out need to be genocide these
are war crimes of unspeakable dimensions
and of course the United States and
other Western actors uh invoked the
responsibility to protect in acting in
Libya to stop a level of violence that
no matter what it was would have been
vastly more modest than what's already
happened in in Syria so the threshold is
there is it then that an ally of the
regime has obstructed well one can make
that argument in this case the key
obstructive figure was Russia not not
China though again Russia had china at
its side as China had Russia at its side
in the case of Dar War so throughout a
year uh of of un Security Council
attempted action the Russians
consistently blocked any attempt to
seriously condemn the Syrian regime in a
way that might
have caused it to Recon consider now
only if you believe that the Assad
government would in fact have responded
in a serious way to such a condemnatory
resolution would you think that's a
legitimate cause and I think I I would
say as as Ed said that was that was
harmful it was unjustifiable but I don't
think it was causitive when we think
about this failure because it seemed to
me then it still seems to be
now that those who are unwilling to act
in a way that they would have had to do
to even have a chance of having changed
the outcome in Syria we're quite happy
to have the Russians as the source of
blame on this you know we'd love to do
something but we can't because the
Russians are blocking Security Council
action even at a time when after some
while it became clear that the security
Council condemnation Security Council
resolution by itself was not going to
change the underlying
circumstance okay then we come to the
third
one is it impossible to to do
anything now this is very much the
position that President Obama has taken
that he recognizes the need to act he
wishes he could act but this is a
situation where unlike Libya it's not
possible to act and let me just read you
something he said in the interview uh
which he gave to the new
Republic he said in a situation like
Syria I have to ask can we make a
difference in that situation would a
military intervention have an impact
could it trigger even worse violence or
the use of chemical weapons what offers
the best Prospect of a stable post Assad
regime and so Obama was in effect
answering his own questions which his
action would be as likely to make things
worse as it would be to improve things
and while we may think that that was a
cynical pretext on his part for inaction
uh I know from having had these
conversations with Susan Rice now the
National Security adviser then the US
ambassador to the UN and a person a
significant part of whose career had to
do with advancing Norms like the
responsibility to protect that she had
the same view I mean this is a
conversation I think I probably had with
her in the fall of 2011 when it first
became clear that this had gone from
being uh a political protest to uh a
Civil War and her position then was no F
Zone wouldn't work cause more problems
than uh it would it would help uh
serious Military Support to the rebels
we don't know who they are and so we
have to trust to the Diplomatic process
so that was very much the uh
administration's view but it's important
to remember that that was part of the
administration's view that we know now
that in
2012 Secretary of State Hillary Clinton
and head of the CIA David Petraeus came
to Obama and said we think we can act
effectively we have a plan for Effective
action which would chiefly involve a
much more serious attempt to bolster the
moderate Rebel forces and Obama said no
so Obama chose to listen to those of his
advisers who said there is no
effective response as opposed to those
who said yes there is an effective
response now we can't drill into his
head and know why he said that why he
came to that conclusion but we do know
from his subsequent actions that he was
very eager to find a way to not act and
so all this became painfully
clear when the when
Assad intentionally or not called
Obama's Bluff when Obama said the one
thing that is our red line is the use of
chemical weapons and then Assad went
from using a small amount of chemical
weapons to as to use Obama's term a
bunch of chemical weapons and so then
that led to this drama in last
September where Obama felt that he was
forced to act plainly did not want to
act and then suddenly at the 11th Hour
got a reprieve from action when uh the
Russians agreed to um help get rid of
Syria's chemical weapons which it's
worth pointing out had not even been an
issue that had been raised publicly
until then at least not in a significant
way and so Obama was then a to say that
he was doing something even though the
something he was doing had only a
tangential if any relationship perhaps
arguably a negative relationship to the
underlying issue of doing something
about atrocities and so that certainly
deeply gave the impression of a man who
wished to find a reason not to act and I
was very struck by something else he
said in that review which also the
pardon me that interview with the new
the new Republic that also gave that
impression he said
um how do I weigh the tens of thousands
who have been killed in Syria versus the
tens of thousands who are currently
being killed in the Congo now Obama knew
the answer to that question he had given
the answer to that question in the case
of Libya where he had said you act where
you
can you don't act where you can't there
may be just as great a moral argument
but if you can't act you don't and he
knew he would have known perfectly well
that the answer to his own question is
the Congo was a case where you couldn't
act Syria is a case where maybe you can
and maybe you can't and so all of that
gives the impression of a man who
was was eager to seize upon the idea
that we're unable to address this for
for tactical reasons not because we lack
the political
will at the same time I think it's much
too easy to say he was a coward he was
afraid of risking his his own uh
political capital and so he chose uh not
to act I think it's a more complicated
uh interaction than that
um and I think if we sort of think about
these categories I've laid out there is
a a kind of terrible self-reinforcing
process between the we can't do it
argument it's too complicated and I
don't want to do it because I fear the
political cost will be too high and here
the example I think of the precedent I
think of is less Rwanda than than the
Balkans and by that I mean not covo but
Bosnia 1993 1994
1995 the reason I say that is that
Rwanda is of course the example the
Supreme example of a failure of
political will but it's also true that
it happened very very quickly and and
once the political will
failed uh then it was all too possible
to say it's it it's it's too late
now I think also in Rwanda it was clear
that you could have done something uh
whereas in Bosnia it was much harder to
say I mean Clinton has later President
Clinton has later said he could have
saved 250,000 people in
ruanda Bosnia was a slow acting atrocity
like Syria it happened over a long long
period of time like
Syria and as in the case of Syria
president quinton's initial thought was
I want to find a reason to not do this
he wanted to find a reason to not do it
because the American people had made it
all too clear they did not want to be
involved in these kinds of foreign
entangle after the catastrophe in
Somalia after kind of not nearly as
great of a mess in Haiti but that
probably didn't help matters
out so Clinton feared doing it and also
believed at the same time that it was
impossible to do that any intervention
could do nothing to really change the
underlying problem which was the ancient
simmering hatreds of that reason he had
read uh Robert kaplan's book Balan
ghosts he was persuaded that this was an
immemorial event that was happening
happening and there was nothing he could
do and so
Clinton chose to believe those who said
there is no effective way of acting both
because there was a strong argument
there was no effective way of acting and
because he knew that there would be
tremendous costs of acting the
likelihood of failure meant that the
political cost of acting were that much
greater because the political costs of
acting are when you fail if you succeed
then at least red Downs to some extent
to your credit as was the case for
example in in Libya with Obama as was
ultimately the case in Haiti where a
kind of failed intervention led to a
successful intervention but so the
greater the likelihood of failure the
more a president is going to feel is
going to fear the political consequences
to himself that's why I say there's a
kind of a terrible interaction between
these two different thoughts uh in the
mind uh of a president now Clinton had
an option of a limited bombing Campaign
which of course he ultimately took when
he when his hand was forced his the the
equivalent for Clinton of the moment
when Assad crossed the red
line through chemical weapons was
shriber forced him to act he acted and
actually succeeded in bringing the
atrocities to an end now of course Obama
doesn't have that option anymore he may
have had it once upon a time
um uh
because of the different nature of the
two conflicts because in Syria you have
had had from the beginning a patchwork
of peoples and forces such that any
bombing action for example the kind of
bombing you might have used in order to
create a noly Zone in order to create a
humanitarian Corridor in order to create
a region where uh uh insurgents could be
safe would inevitably cause uh enormous
numbers of deaths to civilians or let's
say significant numbers of deaths to
civilians you also had the danger that
he always feared of a wider War a wider
war was not a fear in the Balkans in the
same way it was and obviously quite
justifiably a fear in the case of of uh
of Syria um the irony is of course that
that by not acting Obama has wound up
creating something of the situation that
he feared he would create by acting
first of all of course the level of of
of death is grown enormously since he
made that fateful choice in
2012 uh to not do something but
the the more self-interested fears if we
can separate the humanitarian
considerations from the the
self-interested the national interest
considerations those have all come to
pass if not all then certainly most of
them that is to say the fear of a of a
regional destabilization Lebanon is now
in very very grave danger because of the
spillover effect of the war in Syria and
of course we now have a massive jihadist
element that that didn't exist uh before
um and so the the uh irony I
suppose is that there is now a kind of
you might say a realist a national
interest argument for some kind of
forceful intervention in Syria that
didn't exist before though there was
also a national interest argument for a
kind of intervention that would Target
uh the jihadist forces the so-called
ISIS group The U ones who are yet more
crazy than Al-Qaeda uh and I I fear that
Obama ultimately will actually choose to
Target uh those um uh jihadists as
opposed to the the Assad regime but we
actually now see some sign uh of
possible uh decision a possible decision
to increase significantly the level of
support to the rebels this came out in
his conversations or was on the side of
his conversations that Obama just had in
in Saudi Arabia this past week uh but so
the point I want to make though is
that while from the point of view of
Advocates of stronger action it looks
like Obama simply has had a failure of
will the answer I I would say yes he has
but in this self-reinforcing way where
he can tell himself that any action he
chose to make would be a mistake and he
he concedes upon that perfectly
legitimate
claim but I I we have to consider the
fact that the president we're talking
about is the person who we would have
said was the most likely to act in the
face of atrocities he was a president
who was a constitutional lawyer deeply
versed in international law and a deep
believer in international law who had
embraced the responsibility to protect
who had created an atrocity prevention
mechanism who had surrounded himself
with figures like Samantha power Susan
Rice Gale Smith who were all very
important Advocates of the
responsibility to protect so that is a
very
discouraging combination of facts that
even in this case this President found
good reason and I want to emphasize I
think wrong but good reason to choose
not to act in a way that might have had
an effect uh on on on the combat
so what should we infer from this well
first I did not talk about capitals I
talked about Washington
why because it seems to me that in in
many of the situations that for example
Ed described the United States can be a
player on the sideline there are cases
where Regional actors can act there are
places where the United States may play
a
largely either a convening or a
logistical role but when we are talking
about these immense dramas where the
atrocities are already occurring where
it is St state power that is
perpetrating those atrocities it is not
easy to imagine a response that is not
in the end centered around the United
States the US may have led from behind
in Libya but I think it everybody knows
that its its NATO role was absolutely
Central it just did the US did not want
to be seen as playing that Central role
and so because the United States both
accepts in theory this principle and
because it has
unrivaled military power economic power
diplomatic convening
power there will not be a response in
cases like this unless the United States
is prepared to make that response and
the United States I think the lessons go
on to say will not be prepared to make
that response unless
first it has a well first it has a
leader who is committed to doing so
that's hardly to be taken for
granted second
unless the situation seems pretty highly
susceptible of an effective and limited
solution as was the case in Libya as is
not the case in a lot of other places
and perhaps
third and here's a variable which is
negative right now you have an American
public which is prepared to accept the
possibility that things will go
wrong I think right now we're a moment
where the American public is just
deeply uh
uncomfortable with the idea of strong
American action of any kind abroad it's
an American public that has that has
recall that has um um Fallen back into
what we now call the
Homeland and so if there's
any source of hopefulness about any of
this very dark picture that I've
drawn it's that I don't think that this
is a permanent condition of the United
States and of the American public and I
I hope that the time will come when
there is a greater willingness to see
American Force used for moral purposes
and therefore that the price that a
president has to reckon on
paying will not be as high as the price
that Obama obviously feels that he has
to pay so let me stop there thanks very
much